[Music]
travis is with us in indianapolis hi
travis welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon mr ramsey mr campbell how
are you gentlemen doing this afternoon
great brother how can we help
well first of all i just want to say on
behalf of me and my wife that your
program uh your
financial university has been a blessing
to us
god has used your program to be a
blessing in our lives and my wife i i
have to say this if you ever need a new
personality for your program she would
be excellent she she does radiation
and she is she just a beautiful person
beautiful personality and she i mean we
watch your we youtube your episodes so
she she loves your programming so
she just heard on the background she
said i love you dave
well we appreciate it this is awesome
very cool how can we help you guys today
sir
well sir i was calling because
we're at step 3b as you call it where
we're saving for a down payment on a
house okay
and uh i'm 43 my wife would be 39 this
year i'll be 43 tomorrow
and um
right now we have about i would say up
close to twenty thousand dollars saved
for a down payment we got 13 000 in our
emergency fund
and uh the reason why i'm calling this
is that
um
i
i have some concerns about
because we haven't been saving for our
retirement
but we're still saving for our down
payment and considering our age
should we move that snowball that we
accumulated throughout our debt and move
it to move part of it to retirement
while saving part of it for
our um
down payment for our home number one and
number two where do we put that savings
for our down payment do we put that on
top of our
uh emergency fund or do we put that in a
separate account altogether
great questions i like to separate them
personally because i don't want to get
them all mixed up and all of a sudden
the house down payment becomes part of
the emergency fund so i like to just
separate them having a different high
yield savings account or money market
savings account that's fine and to your
other point you guys at your age 43 and
39 it's a valid question should we start
investing while saving up the down
payment and there's a few ways to go
about 3b some people they start
investing 15 while saving up down
payment some people split the difference
maybe invest up to the match from your
employer while setting up the down
payment and some people do zero
investing and go all in on the down
payment it sounds like in your case
you're getting a little antsy doing
nothing in retirement right now correct
yeah that's what it sounds like and so
i think the whole point is um
you know you can decide if you want to
go ahead and buy a house with twenty
thousand dollars down uh you're gonna
end up probably with pmi in that case
private mortgage insurance because
you're not putting down twenty percent
but um you know on a first-time home
purchase we don't tell people you know
he's just warn you about pmi but we
don't yell at you for not putting down a
full 20
second home you should sit on your tail
until you have 20 percent i mean you
know because you should avoid pmi but
when you're trying to save up and scrape
up and you guys have been working this
diligently uh if you want to go and buy
with twenty thousand dollars down if
it'll get you in the house i don't know
if it will or not i don't know what
we're looking at here
uh but uh if you wanna continue to say
we tell people not to not to do zero
retirement between three and baby step
three and baby step four to not get
stuck there at 3b more than three years
at zero so uh i mean it can be three and
a half but i mean i don't want you
saving for a down payment for ten years
and not doing retirement so that's the
point of the whole thing